the explosion of new ways to reach
customers is putting a lot of strain on
our IT teams and infrastructures the
pace of API and mobile application
innovation the need for quicker time to
market across business areas and other
challenges are outstripping the ability
to plan manage and secure these new
channels enter IBM data power gateway a
cost-effective and proven solution to
your edge of the network needs data
power gateways are found in many Fortune
500 companies protecting vital assets
from the increasing danger of attacks
whether you're protecting and optimizing
api's mobile applications b2b cloud or
web services data power can help you
control and secure your traffic data
power gateways provide mobile API and
other sample services to quickly
implement these channels with proven
best practices data power gateways are
specialized consumable purpose-built
gateways that combine superior
performance and hardened security data
power solutions come in physical virtual
cloud Linux and docker form factors
physical gateways provide encrypted
storage intrusion detection optional
onboard hardware security modules and
hardware based cryptographic
acceleration data power gateway virtual
edition can be used for on-premise or
cloud deployments and supports many
popular hypervisors since both physical
and virtual data power gateways use the
same firmware the deployment process
remains consistent throughout your
software development lifecycle
you can also provision and deploy data
power gateway as a docker container for
enhanced Portability and elasticity on
cloud and micro service platforms data
power gateways support a broad range of
Industry and government standards and
regulations and are updated as new
standards emerge this offloads the work
of maintaining industry compliance from
your development teams and existing
servers data powers robust wire speed
execution
supports conversions between popular
protocols and data types
swiftly enabling new applications and
clients to leverage existing
capabilities for new opportunities for
instance you can take an existing
service that's accessible via IBM's MQ
middleware and make it accessible via
JSON over a rest interface for modern
devices as your IT needs rapidly evolve
data power gateways provide a proven
solution to secure managed control and
optimize your growing edge of the
network requirements data power also
helps you manage internal traffic so you
control what is accessing what with a
central governance point for system to
system interactions visit ibm.com slash
data power and see what IBM data power
gateways can do for you